[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
con los prototipos de los trajes que
usarán los astronautas que lleguen a la
luna como parte de la misión artemis
tres prevista para despegar en 2025 la
NASA los presentó como una verdadera
Revolución la nueva generación de trajes
permitirá movimientos más naturales
cuentan con una escotilla trasera e
incluyen sistemas que buscan brindar no
solo seguridad sino también comodidad De
los astronautas la banda de esta luz
está montada en el conjunto de la visera
en la burbuja del casco y esto
esencialmente les da los astronautas
luces para ver cuando están en puntos
sombreados de la luna o si están en
órbita terrestre bajo un periodo
nocturno pueden encender estas luces
También tenemos una cámara de video HD
por lo que lo que recolectamos podemos
verlo en alta definición que será una
actualización fantástica a partir de la
tecnología actual
recordemos que está previsto que la
misión en el Polo Sur de nuestro
satélite un territorio de gran interés
para varias potencias entre ellas china
que podría enviar una misión robótica
Pues los trajes Fueron confeccionados
por acción space y tienen todo lo
necesario para que los astronautas que
pisen el satélite de la tierra no tengan
que sufrir con los 50 grados Celsius que
puede haber en las zonas iluminadas y
los 200 grados bajo cero en zonas
sombreadas
No hemos tenido trajes nuevos desde los
diseñados para el programa de
transportadores espaciales y esos trajes
se usan actualmente en la estación
espacial
es decir que durante 40 años hemos usado
los mismos trajes con la misma
tecnología
ahora acción está innovando van a tomar
lo que la NASA ha proveído de las
pruebas que hemos hecho y ahora los
trajes tendrán mayor funcionalidad mejor
desempeño y más capacidades
Aunque el prototipo presentado es negro
con naranja la NASA fue explicando que
el traje que se usará será blanco se
prevé que este mismo uniforme con
algunas modificaciones sirvan el futuro
no solo para realizar caminatas fuera de
la estación espacial y la futura
estación lunar Gateway sino también en
la exploración de marte
cambiamos de tema y vamos a Ucrania
donde la compañía británica de prótesis
biónicas impresas en 3D Open bionics
presentó su llamado
o brazo Heroico una extremidad biónica
diseñada para soldados que han perdido
manos o brazos en medio de la guerra son
prótesis con dedos funcionales y
pulgares que se controlan mediante
sensores mío eléctricos que registran
los impulsos eléctricos generados por
los músculos se trata de una iniciativa
en conjunto con la ong ucraniana super
humans que financió la construcción de
un centro de rehabilitación cerca de la
ciudad del VIP Andy y vitali son dos
soldados ucranianos que ya tienen sus
prótesis
mi primera impresión es que es genial
puede hacer cosas elementales con esta
prótesis
puedo tomar cosas con la mano como una
bolsa y hacer las compras Y entonces mi
otra mano está libre para sostener mi
teléfono
incluso mis amigos me preguntaban si
tendría la prótesis me decían que
quieren saludarme de modo normal no
apretar mi mano izquierda sino la
derecha como es costumbre
fue la primera compañía que desarrolló
manos impresas en 3D aprobadas
clínicamente y trabajan con el centro
super humans Desde allí aseguran que
aunque no tienen capacidad para atender
a corto plazo a todos los pacientes que
requieren de estas prótesis esperan
poder ayudar a un alto número de
personas a quienes se les realizan
múltiples pruebas porque la labor no
consiste en entregar cualquier prótesis
sino una que esté personalizada para que
funcion correctamente
no sabemos exactamente Cuántas personas
han sufrido en esta guerra porque el
número es secreto pero creemos que más
de 10.000 ucranianos necesitan implantes
protésicos planeamos ofrecer nuestro
servicio a unas 3.000 personas por año
lo que no será suficiente pero prevemos
ampliar los servicios de súper humanos
en otras regiones ucranianas ya tenemos
planeadas oficinas en otras cinco
regiones
continuamos en Países Bajos para conocer
una interesante y al mismo tiempo
rudimentaria iniciativa que es muy común
en Europa y Estados Unidos existen
uganda en África pero no es tan famosa
en América Latina o Asia estamos
hablando de los reaper café o cafés de
reparación como su nombre lo sugiere son
cafés o establecimientos donde las
personas llevan electrodomésticos a
reparar la particularidad es que quienes
atienden son voluntarios que tienen
conocimientos en la materia por lo que
la reparación es gratuita la intención
es Clara un aparato re significa menos
desechos para el planeta
es genial lo mejor es llegar a casa en
la noche después de un día de trabajo
sabiendo que ayudaste a mucha gente que
también se fue feliz a casa Hay muchas
cosas buenas al respecto es bueno para
el medio ambiente menos basura etcétera
alrededor del 80% de las cosas que traen
podemos arreglarlas y es muy
satisfactorio para los clientes pero
también para nosotros como mecánicos
según los responsables solo en este café
de reparación en ámsterdam se han
arreglado aparatos que equivaldrían a
unos 7.000 kilos de desechos Claro en el
pasado era más común encontrar
reparadores porque era más costoso
comprar un nuevo aparato que arreglarlo
pero en el presente los repuestos a
veces cuestan más no obstante Los
Defensores de los jefes café aseguran
que con la inflación al alzan numerosos
países del Mundo esta iniciativa podría
ser clave no solo para el medio ambiente
sino también para el bolsillo
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúan con nosotros en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]